[Music]
more than a decade after the 911 attacks
a new world trade center is finally
rising along with a memorial museum and
a transit hub when the projects are
slated to open they'll supposedly
symbolize America's strength
determination and refusal to give in but
they really tell a different story about
taxpayer ripoffs public sector and
confidence and union and corporate greed
One World Trade Center formerly known as
the Freedom Tower will be the most
expensive office building in American
history by a long shot the port
authority of new york and new jersey the
public agency that's running the show is
sticking commuters with part of the tab
by hiking tolls across the hudson river
to $12 conde nast the flush publisher of
The New Yorker wired and Vanity Fair got
muku subsidies to move in and who other
than the federal government signed on to
fill up five floors at a cost of 351
million dollars over 20 years even the
New York Times stimulus pimping
columnist Joe Nocera has called World
Trade Center rebuilding an example of
just about everything wrong with modern
government asking where's the tea party
when you need them just down the street
from the Trade Center this federally
financed transit hub is a billion
dollars over budget it's 3.4 billion
dollars construction costs for the sep
tember 11th memorial and museum have
climbed to seven hundred million dollars
with taxpayers footing a portion of the
bill new york's politically connected
construction industry has benefited most
from the 911 largesse but the city's
real estate and banking cartels have
also gone whole hog at the
taxpayer-funded trough the bush
administration gave New York 8 billion
dollars in tax free Liberty Bonds only
to see a big portion of that go for
projects that have nothing to do with
September 11th Brooklyn
Atlantic Yards benefited from subsidized
bonds as did a midtown Manhattan office
project even goldman sachs which has
nearly a trillion dollars in assets got
almost two million dollars toward its
new headquarters since when did honoring
the dead become an occasion for fleecing
the living after September 11th small
townships in New Jersey and Long Island
quickly built modest but moving
memorials to pay tribute to the loved
ones they lost in the attacks and lower
Manhattan something else is being built
an overdue over-budget monument
representing how politicians bureaucrats
and opportunists spend other people's
money with each for recent TV I'm
Kennedy
[Music]